एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड इवनिंग
टू ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
प्लीज जल्दी से चैट में बता दीजिए। यस या
नो।
क्या सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
सुनाई दे रही है?
ओके
चलो भाई थैंक यू अगर सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई
दे रही है तो एंड अगेन
सबको गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल मेरी तरफ से गुड
इवनिंग। ओके कैसे हो आप सब लोग? और कितने
लोग हैं आज फर्स्ट टाइम आज क्लास मेरे
पहली क्लास है उनकी डेफोनिक्स एकडमी पर इस
सीरीज की पहली क्लास है। कितने लोग ऐसे
हैं जिनकी
आज पहली क्लास है? मतलब पहले कभी आए हैं
मेरी क्लासेस में खासकर इस कोर्स के अंदर
नो प्रॉब्लम। आज जिसकी फर्स्ट क्लास है वो
बताइए। कितने लोग हैं आज?
है कोई आज डायरेक्ट आज? आज आज पहली बार ही
क्लास में आए हैं।
ओके। आपकी पहली क्लास है।
ओके। तो, यह सीरीज के बारे में आपको
इंट्रोडक्शन दे देता हूं। यह इस सीरीज का
नाम है डीईएई सीरीज। डेफोनिक्स एथिकल हैकर
एसेंशियल सीरीज मतलब एक एथिकल हैकिंग की
सीरीज है। एथिकल हैकिंग में पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग। ओके? और इसका जो स्टैंडर्ड्स
है, इसका वो इसका स्टैंडर्ड सेट किया गया
है इंडस्ट्री लेवल। मतलब कि इंडस्ट्री में
जिस तरीके से पेन टेस्टिंग की जाती है उस
टाइप से जैसे कि अगर आप कोई भी ईजीपीटी या
ईसीपीपीटी
मतलब जो आईएई के दो सर्टिफिकेशन पेन
टेस्टिंग है अगर आप उनकी तैयारी कर रहे हो
तो आसानी से वो एग्जाम आप दे सकते हो।
दूसरी अगर आप कोई भी एथ एथिकल हैकिंग की
तैयारी कर रहे हो या एथिकल हैकिंग में
एंट्री करने की कोशिश कर रहे हो बिगिनियर
टू एक इंटरमीडिएट लेवल। बेसिकली इतना हाई
लेवल नहीं ना ज्यादा इंटरमीडिएट बट
इंटरमीडिएट तक के लेवल तक की एक सीरीज है
जिसमें आपको बहुत कुछ अभी तक सिखाया गया
है और बहुत कुछ सिखाने वाले हैं। यह क्लास
हमने स्टार्ट की थी बहुत पहले और यह अभी
कंटिन्यू चल रही है। इसमें हमने बिल्कुल
जीरो से स्टार्ट किया था। तो अगर आपको
एथिकल हैकिंग में इंटरेस्ट है आपको सीखना
है तो आप क्या कीजिए इस सीरीज़ को
कंटिन्यू। हमारे डेफ्रोनिक्स एकडमी के
चैनल पे एक प्लेलिस्ट है डीईएई की जिसमें
आज की क्लास भी अपडेट होगी और हो गई होगी
तो उसमें लाइव में दिखाएगी तो आप वहां पर
जाकर इस सीरीज को देख सकते हो अंडरस्टुड
ओके ओके ओके
अच्छी बात है फिर
तो स्टूडेंट्स मुझे लगता है नहीं आए
दो मिनट का एक मिनट का और वेट कर लेते
हैं। तो आपका अगर कोई डाउट है रिलेटेड टू
द सीरीज खासकर जो नए हैं कुछ पूछना चाहते
हैं कि सर यह सीखने को मिलेगा नहीं मिलेगा
या ओल्ड स्टूडेंट है जिनका प्रीवियस
क्लासेस से रिलेटेड कोई भी डाउट है तो वह
पूछ सकते हैं क्योंकि टॉपिक सबके लिए नया
है। यह YouTube पर नहीं है।
यह टॉपिक YouTube पर नहीं होगा। यह मैं
बोल सकता हूं।
बताइए किसी का कोई डाउट है क्लास से
रिलेटेड
कोई डाउट नहीं है?
चलो स्लाइड पर चल पड़ते हैं।
ठीक है? क्लास से रिलेटेड कोई डाउट नहीं
है। मैं आपकी चैट देख रहा हूं।
क्लास से रिलेटेड कोई डाउट नहीं है। बताओ
जी। हेलो राजे 06
ऑल क्लियर टेक्नो ऑफ द फर्स्ट क्लास आप
कैसे ऑल क्लियर बोल सकते हो
ओके राधे आप नए हो तो राधे फ्री एथिकल
हैकिंग सीरीज की क्लास है और इसमें काफी
कुछ बिल्कुल शुरू से सिखाया जा रहा है
तो इसको मिस मत करना इस क्लासेस को
बिल्कुल स्टार्टिंग से भी देखना जैसे-जैसे
आपको टाइम मिलता है और अभी आप क्लास के
बीच में आए हो तो यह जो टॉपिक है जो अभी
प्रेजेंट टॉपिक चल रहा है क्लास 60 से चल
रहा है। इससे पहले हम कुछ और टॉपिक कवर कर
चुके हैं।
ओके चलिए फिर हम सेशन को स्टार्ट करते
हैं। तो आज का टॉपिक है हमारा ओडीए लूप।
ओडीए मतलब ऑब्जर्व ओरिएंट।
ओके? ऑब्जर्व ओरिएंट डिसाइड और एक्ट इसका
नाम है। ऑब्जर्व ओरिएंट डिसाइड और एक्ट
इसका नाम है आज की क्लास का नाम। अब यह
क्या है? कहां पर काम करता है? कैसे काम
करता है? और यह ऑब्जर्व ओरिएंट, डिसाइड और
एक्ट क्या चीजें हैं? इनके बारे में हम
बात करने वाले हैं। यह चिंता मत कीजिए।
तो, ओडी लूप के बारे में पढ़ने से पहले
मैं आपका एक कंफ्यूजन क्लियर कर दूंगा।
अगर आपके मन में आया होगा तो क्योंकि अगर
आपने ध्यान से पढ़ा होगा अगर ध्यान से
क्लासेस को देखा होगा आई एम श्योर कि वो
कंफ्यूजन आपके मन में आना चाहिए था और
नहीं आया तो प्लीज मैं आपको बता देता हूं
अगर आपको याद होगा क्लास 60 में मैंने
आपको पढ़ा 61 में मैंने आपको पढ़ाया था
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक मेथोडोलॉजी के बारे में
ठीक है क्लाइंट साइड अटैक मेथोलॉजी के
बारे में जिसमें मैंने आपको टोटल सात मेथ
मेथोडोलॉजी पढ़ाई थी सात फेजेस जिसके बारे
में बताया था रिकॉन टारगेट आइडेंटिफिकेशन
पेलोड रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट पेलोड प्रिपेरेशन
पेलोड डिलीवरी एग्जीक्यूशन पोस्ट
एक्सप्लइटेशन याद है जो पुराने स्टूडेंट
हैं उनको पता है यह चीज मैंने बताई थी
आपको यह सात फेजेस बताए थे क्या नाम है
इनका जगत गुरु जी डिड यू रिमेंबर
राधे मैं सचिन सर ही हूं यार आपका का
डिड यू रिमेंबर गाइस आपको याद है जो जिनने
क्लास देखी है जिसने रिकॉर्डिंग देखी है
अगर आपको याद है कि ये सात फेजेस मैंने
अपने क्लास 61 में बताया था और काफी डिटेल
में बताया था रिकॉन में क्या होता है
टारगेट आइडेंटिफिकेशन में क्या होता है तो
मैंने उसके बाद आपको सिखाया था सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक साइकिल अटैक लाइफ साइकिल
यह भी मैंने आपको बताया था इसमें भी सात
फेज के बारे में जिक्र किया था जो क्लास
क्लास हमने पढ़ी थी कौन सी? 69 और 70 में
हमने इसके बारे में पढ़ा था सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक लाइफ साइकिल जिसमें
मैंने सातों फेज के बारे में काफी डिटेल
में आपको एक्सप्लेन किया था। हमने डिस्कस
किया था। सबसे पहला फज़ था स्कोपिंग फेज,
फिर उसके बाद रिकॉन फेज, डिज़ एंड अप्रूवल
फेज, इंप्लीमेंटेशन फेज, डिटेक्शन फेज,
मेजरमेंट फेज और रिपोर्टिंग फेज। मैंने
आपको यह बताया था। और मैं सोच रहा था कि
आप लोग यह डाउट पूछें। लेकिन आपने आप में
से किसी ने भी यह डाउट नहीं पूछा क्या कि
सर आपने यह चीजें बताई हैं क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक
मेथोलॉजी में आपको बताया है यह सात फेजेस
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक लाइफ साइकिल में
आपने भी यह सात फेजेस बताए हैं। बट सर हम
पढ़ रहे हैं एक्सटर्नल पेन टेस्टिंग और
एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग में हम
क्या टॉपिक डिस्कस कर रहे हैं? क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक मेथोलॉजी के बारे में डिस्कस कर
रहे हैं। किन के बारे में डिस्कस कर रहे
हैं? क्लाइंट साइड अटैक मेथोलॉजी के बारे
में ही हम डिस्कस कर रहे हैं। बट सर यह
बताओ कि जब आपने स्टार्टिंग में सात फेजेस
बता दिए फिर ये अलग से क्यों बताए और ये
फेजेस अलग क्यों है? किसी के मन में डाउट
नहीं आया। ठीक है? और आना चाहिए था। क्या
डिफरेंस है? लेकिन मैं आपको एक
सिंपल शब्दों में बता देता हूं कि जो सात
फेजेस हैं ये वाले जो ये सात फेजेस हैं
बेसिकली ये इसी का थोड़ा सा एक्सटेंडेड
वर्जन है। बेसिकली हम क्या कर रहे हैं? जो
ये टैक्टिक्स हैं टैिक्स हम वही यूज़ कर
रहे हैं। क्लाइंट साइड अटैक मेथोलॉजी
वाली। लेकिन हम क्या कर रहे हैं? सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में इन्हीं में से कुछ ज्यादा
और कम करके हम क्या कर रहे हैं? थोड़ा सा
और एक्सप्लोर कर रहे हैं। क्योंकि
यह तो क्या है? ब्रॉडर व्यू है और यह उसका
क्या है? और भी नैरो डाउन करें तो हम इसको
या उसके अंदर और ज्यादा एक्सपेंड करें। तो
एक्सपेंड करने पर हम क्या करते हैं? सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में यह टैक्टिक यूज़ करते हैं।
तो मैं इनका कंपैरिजन करके दिखाता हूं
आपको कि कौन सी टैक्टिक कैसे? तो जैसे
सबसे पहले मैं बताता हूं सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
में स्कोपिंग फज़ है। इसमें स्कोपिंग फज़
नहीं है। लेकिन स्कोपिंग फज़ हमेशा किसी भी
पेन टेस्टिंग का सबसे पहला पार्ट होता है
स्कोपिंग फज़। किसी भी पेन टेस्टिंग का
सबसे पहला फज़ होता है स्कोपिंग फज़। ठीक
है? हमने डायरेक्टली रिकॉन टारगेट
आइडेंटिफिकेशन पे लोड रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट
ये सारी चीजें डिस्कस कर ली लेकिन हर एक
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग का सबसे पहला फज़ होता
है स्कोपिंग फज़ इसलिए ये स्कोपिंग फज़ है
क्योंकि यहां पर हमने बताया था लेकिन यहां
पर हमने और ज्यादा एक्सप्लेन किया तो
स्कोपिंग फज़ को भी ऐड कर दिया ठीक है
स्कोपिंग फेज का मतलब क्या था कि हम स्कोप
डिस्कस करते हैं रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट या
स्टेटमेंट ऑफ वर्क वहां पर क्या करते हैं
या एक कॉन्ट्रैक्ट साइन करते हैं एक
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट डिसाइड होता है जहां पर आपको
क्या करना है क्या नहीं करना मतलब आपके
आपके लिए बाउंड्री साइड की जाती है
स्कोपिंग ऑफ फेज अब बात आते हैं हम फिर
उसकी यहां पर रिकॉन एंड टारगेट
आइडेंटिफिकेशन फज़ की। तो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
के साथ अगर कंपेयर करते हम जो हमने पढ़ाया
था तो ये दोनों जो स्टेप है कौन सा? रिकॉन
एंड टारगेट आइडेंटिफिकेशन। हमने दोनों को
क्या कर दिया? मर्ज कर दिया यहां पर किस
में? रिकॉन फेज में ओसेंट गैदरिंग में।
बिल्कुल मर्ज ही हो गया। क्योंकि रिकॉन और
टारगेट आइडेंटिफिकेशन है तो लगभग सेम चीज
ही। तो यहां पर हमने क्या कर दिया? वहां
पर दो अलग-अलग आपको फज़ बताए थे, स्टेज
बताए यहां पर एक स्टेज में कवर होते हैं।
तो बोथ आर बोथ आर एसेंशली द सेम। द ओनली
डिफरेंस इज़ सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। यू गैदर
डिटेल्स। मतलब इसमें क्या है कि सोशल
इंजीनियर में क्या है कि आप ह्यूमन
एलिमेंट के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर करते
हो। जब जबकि मैंने आपको बताया था क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक्स में भी आप क्या करते हो?
सिस्टम और सॉफ्टवेयर के बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करते हो। लेकिन बात
ऐसी है आप सोशल इंजीनियरिंग करो या सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग से भी आपका मेन पर्पस क्या
है? एक जो ह्यूमन एलिमेंट है जो वहां पर
जो लोग हैं उनको क्या करना है एक्सप्लइट
करना है उनके लिए प्रिटेक्स जनरेट करना है
उनसे इंफॉर्मेशन लेना है इंफॉर्मेशन लास्ट
में हम क्या लेते हैं सिस्टम सॉफ्टवेयर की
लेते हैं क्योंकि हमें क्या करना है अपना
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक को सक्सेसफुल बनाना है
नेक्स्ट आपका स्टेप आया फेज जी मैंने आपको
बताया था आपका आ गया इस यहां पर क्लाइंट
साइड में आया था आपका पेलोड एंड रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट यहां पर हमने क्या लिखा उसका
नाम क्या बोला डिजाइंड एंड अप्रूवल जिसको
हम बोल सकते हैं वेपनाइजिंग ओसेंट ओके तो
जैसे कि सोशल इंडिया अटैक की बात करें
जहां पर हम फेक इसके अंदर क्या करते हैं
फेक एचआर लॉग इन पेज बना दिया हम क्या
करते हैं अपने आप को प्रिटेंड करते हैं
किसी सीईओ के रूप में किसी वेंडर के रूप
में या किसी थर्ड पार्टी सर्विस के रूप
में वहीं पर क्या करते हैं अगर इसमें बात
करें क्लाइंट साइड अटैक के बारे में यहां
पर हम टेक्निकल एक्सप्लइटरी रिसोर्सेज को
भी क्या करते हैं फाइंड आउट करते हैं
क्योंकि एंड ऑफ द डे क्या होता है जब हम
कंपनी को कंप्रोमाइज करेंगे उसके लिए एक
बिल्कुल रियल अटैक परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं
तो वहां से क्या करेंगे? डाटा कलेक्ट
करेंगे। डाटा कलेक्ट करके उसके बाद जो
सॉफ्टवेयर है जैसे Chrome है या Firefox
है या MS Word है या MS Office है तो उसका
अगर वर्जन हमारे पास मिला तो उसके उसके
लिए भी हम क्या करते हैं एक टेक्निकल
एक्सप्लइट तो हम बैकग्राउंड में रेडी करते
ही है ना क्योंकि हमने क्या किया एक फेक
लॉग इन पेज भेजा वहां पर क्लिक किया
बैकग्राउंड में कोई एक्सप्लइट रन करवा
लिया रिवर्स इंजरी ओ रिवर्स सेल के लिए
चीज़ वही है बट क्या किया है कि यहां पर
थोड़ा सा नाम डिफरेंशिएट डिफरेंशिएट किया
गया नाम को लेकिन काम लगभग दोनों का सेम
है नेक्स्ट मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन करूं। फिर
हमने यहां पर बताया था तीन स्टेप पेलोड
प्रिपेरेशन, पेलोड डिलीवरी और
एग्जीक्यूशन। तो यहां पर ये एक ही फज़ में
आ गया। किस में? इंप्लीमेंटेशन फज़ में।
सेम वही है। इंप्लीमेंटेशन फज़ में आप क्या
करते हो? डिज़ अप्रूवल में आपने प्रीक्स्ट
बनाया। उसके बाद अप्रूवल मिल गया। उसके
बाद आप क्या करते हो? जो पेलोड है उसके जो
आपको अटैक करना है उसके लिए एक एक्सप्लइट
रेडी करते हो। उसके बाद उसको डिलीवर करते
हो। उसके बाद उसको एग्जीक्यूट करवाते हो।
तो इंप्लीमेंटेशन फेज वही तो है
एग्जीक्यूशन फेज। इंप्लीमेंटेशन फेज में
तीनों चीज ही होती हैं जो मैंने आपको
बताया था। ओके? दिस इज द बिगेस्ट कनेक्शन
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग। इंप्लीमेंटेशन मींस
टेकिंग द अटैक लाइव। इन टेक्निकल टर्म्स
दिस मींस यू हैव प्रिपयर्ड द पेलोड
प्रिपेरेशन सेंटेड बाय ईमेल। उसके बाद
ट्रिग्ड द यूजर इनू क्लिकिंग एंड रनिंग इट
एग्जीक्यूशन। वही चीज तो है। बट यहां पर
क्या है? हमने इन तीनों को क्या कर दिया?
इसमें मर्ज कर दिया। बट ये इसका
एक्सटेंडेड है। यहां पर पहले अलग तरीके से
आपको पता चल रहा है क्योंकि पहले मैंने
हाई लेवल हाई ओवरव्यू दिया था आपको। यह
बताया था कि क्लाइंट साइड अटैक मेथड्स
कौन-कौन से होते हैं। उसके बाद सोशल
इंजीनियर अटैक लाइफ साइकिल पे गए। तो हमने
थोड़ा सा इसको और इबोरेट कर दिया। थोड़ा
सा और एक्सपेंड कर दिया। तो अभी आपको
नेक्स्ट हम डिस्कस किया डिटेक्शन फज़।
डिटेक्शन फज़ के बारे में हमने पता था क्या
क्या करता है कि आप अकेले वहां पर
पार्टिसिपेट नहीं कर रहे। आप अकेले नहीं
खेल रहे। वहां पर डिफेंडर्स भी है, ब्लू
टीमर्स भी हैं। वो आपको डिटेक्ट कर पूरी
पूरी कोशिश करेंगे आपको डिटेक्ट करने की
रियल टाइम में आपको ब्लॉक करने की। तो ये
आ गया आपका डिटेक्शन फज़ आ गया। नेक्स्ट
बात करें यहां पर पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन की।
यहां पर जो पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन है, यह तभी
होगा जब आपका मेजरमेंट फज़ होगा। क्योंकि
आपने क्या किया? एग्जीक्यूशन तो कर लिया।
मेजरमेंट फज़ में आप क्या करते हो? आप क्या
करते हो? हाउ मेनी पीपल्स क्लिक द लिंक
एंड सबमिटेड देयर क्रेडेंशियल्स। यहां पर
आप यह डाटा कलेक्ट करते हो। कितने लोगों
ने उस लिंक पर क्लिक किया या कितने लोगों
ने अपने क्रेडेंशियल्स सबमिट किए। उसके
बाद क्या है कि जब तक वह क्लिक नहीं
करेंगे जब तक वह अपने क्रेडेंशियल सबमिट
नहीं करे तब तक आपका जो पोस्ट
एक्सप्लइटेशन फेस है वह काम ही नहीं
करेगा। तब तक वो काम ही नहीं करेगा। मतलब
बेसिकली कहें तो मेजरमेंट फज़ पे आप क्या
करते हो? डाटा को कलेक्ट करते हो रिपोर्ट
के लिए और उसके बाद डिपेंड करता है अगर
आपके जो रूल्स ऑफ इंगेजमेंट है आपका जो
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट है बोलता है कि नहीं
कंप्लीटली कंप्रोमाइज करके दिखाना है आपको
पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन फेज भी आपको
एग्जीक्यूट करके दिखाना है तो मेजरमेंट
फेज के बाद आप क्या करते हो पोस्ट
एक्सप्लइटेशन फेज को ही यूज करते हो
नेक्स्ट बात आती है हमारी फिर जैसा आपको
पता है रिपोर्टिंग ये सबको समझ में आ गया
दोनों का डिफरेंस कि कंफ्यूज नहीं होना है
चीज सेम है थोड़ा सा एक्सपेंडेड वर्जन है
रिकॉन और इन दोनों को मिला दिया गया तो यह
बन गया कैसा इसके अंदर रिकॉन फज़ के अंदर
यह सेम ही है इन तीनों को मिलाकर आपका
बनता है इंप्लीमेंटेशन फज़ उसके बाद
डिटेक्शन फेज इंडिविजुअल है सो स्कोपिंग
फज़ इंडिविजुअल है रिपोर्टिंग फज़ आपको पता
है पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन मेजरमेंट फेज के
बाद होता है यहां तक क्लियर है तीनों चीज
अभी यह डाउट आपके मन में आना चाहिए था बट
मैंने आपके लिए यह आंसर कर दिया यह आप
लोगों को समझ में आ गया होगा यह क्लियर है
डाउट आप लोगों के लिए
अंडरस्टुड बताइए ये चीज समझ में आई आपको
ये चीज आपको क्लियर है?
क्लियर है?
अरे बताओ मेरे को थोड़ा सा बताओ तो सही।
बस एक ही स्टूडेंट की क्लियर है। बाकी
किसी को नहीं पता क्या चल रहा है क्लास
में। हो तो मुझे पता है चार पांच ही हो तो
क्या चार या पांचों में से एक को ही पता
है। बाकी लोग इंटैक्ट नहीं करोगे लाइव
क्लास में।
क्या आप लोगों को कोई इंटरेस्ट नहीं है?
बताइए। कोई भी इंटरेस्ट नहीं है आपका?
कोई भी इंटरेस्ट नहीं है।
बताओ
बताइए कोई भी इंटरेस्ट नहीं है यस या नो
ओके चलिए अभी हम एक केस स्टडी पे बात करते
हैं। ओडी लूप को समझने से पहले एक केस
स्टडी है। एक रियल वर्ल्ड केस स्टडी है
जिसके बारे में बात करने वाले हैं। यह
कहानी है सितंबर 2019 की और यह एक रियल
इंसिडेंट है। ठीक है और यह साइबर
सिक्योरिटी हिस्ट्री का सबसे बड़ा सबक था।
ठीक है? यह सबसे बड़ा सबक है। कैसे?
क्योंकि ये कहां पर हुआ था ये? 2019 में
यूएसए में हुआ था। लोवा के अंदर। कहां पर
हुआ था? यूएसए में। यूएसए स्टेट के अंदर
यूनाइटेड स्टेट ऑफ अमेरिका के अंदर जो
लोवा स्टेट है उसके अंदर ये इंसिडेंट हुआ
था। सितंबर 2019 में सितंबर 2019 में यह
इंसिडेंट एक्चुअल में था क्या मैं आपको
बताता हूं और काफी इंटरेस्टिंग इंसिडेंट
है। उसके बाद आपको ओडी में ओडी लूप पढ़ने
में मजा भी आएगा। तो केस स्टडी में क्या
है कि जब स्कोपिंग फेल होती है ना उसके
सरकमस्ट्ससेस क्या होते हैं? मैं आपको
बताता हूं। तो जो एक थी कोल फायर नाम की
एक साइबर सिक्योरिटी कंपनी थी। ठीक है? एक
प्रोफेशनल साइबर सिक्योरिटी कंपनी है। ठीक
है? उस उसमें क्या हुआ था कि दो जो दो
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स थे ना ठीक है? उनको
अरेस्ट कर लिया गया था। अरेस्ट करके जेल
में डाल दिया गया था। ठीक है?
कोल फायर कंपनी के दो पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स
को अरेस्ट करके जेल में डाल दिया गया था।
क्यों डाल दिया गया था? क्योंकि वो रात को
कहां पर? जो डोलस कंट्रीज ऑफ कोर्ट हाउस
है डालास कंट्री कोर्ट हाउस है फिजिकल
इनफिल्ट्रेशन करने की कोशिश कर रहे थे टू
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स वर ट्राइंग टू
फिजिकली इनफिल्ट्रेट या फोर्सफुली एंटर द
डोलास कंट्री डालास कंट्री कंट्री कोर्ट
हाउस एट नाइट रात में क्या कर रहे थे वह
इनफिजिकली इनफिल्ट्रेट करने की कोशिश कर
रहे थे किसके अंदर इसके अंदर डेलस कंट्री
कोर्ट हाउस के अंदर। अब ट्विस्ट की बात
सुनो। उनके पास कॉन्ट्रैक्ट था। ठीक है?
उनके पास कॉन्ट्रैक्ट था। उनको किसने
ऑथराइज किया था? लोवा स्टेट कोर्ट
एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन एससीए स्टेट कोर्ट
एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन ने उनको ऑथराइज किया था।
उनके पास एक कॉन्ट्रैक्ट भी था। ठीक है?
जिसमें लिखा हुआ था दे हैव अ वैलिड
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट हैज ऑथराइज देम टू टेस्ट द
सिक्योरिटी ऑफ देयर इलेक्ट्रॉनिक्स
रिकॉर्ड। उनके पास एक ऑथराइजेशन लेटर था।
उनके पास एक ऑथराइजेशन नोट था कि वो क्या
कर सकते हैं? लोवा की इलेक्ट्रॉनिक्स
रिकॉर्ड की सिक्योरिटी टेस्टिंग करें।
उनके पास यह अथॉरिटी थी। ठीक है? उनके पास
यह अथॉरिटी थी। आप बोलोगे तो सर जब उनके
पास अथॉरिटी थी फिर भी दोनों पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर्स को अरेस्ट क्यों कर लिया गया?
अरेस्ट करने में के कारण अभी अभी डिस्कस
करने वाले हैं। प्रॉब्लम क्या हुई? जो
एससीए था स्टेट कोर्ट एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स।
ठीक है? उन्होंने क्या कहा? उन्होंने कहा
कि हमारा मतलब था सिर्फ डिजिटल टेस्टिंग
करने का। हम हमने कहा था आपको डिजिटल
टेस्टिंग करनी है। हमने कभी कभी ना तो यह
सोचा था ना हमने आपको कभी बोला था कि रात
को आप दीवार कूदकर फिजिकल बिल्डिंग में
घुस जाए। ठीक है? उन्होंने बोला आवर
इंटेंशन वाज़ ओनली डिजिटल टेस्टिंग। वी
नेवर एक्सपेक्टेड देम टू फिजिकली एंटर
इंटू द बिल्डिंग। जो एससीएस का जो
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट था उनका जो व्यू था उन्होंने
कहा कि हमने सिर्फ डिजिटल टेस्टिंग करने
के लिए बोला था। हमने सोचा भी नहीं था कि
आप रात को दीवार कूदकर बिल्डिंग के अंदर
फिजिकली इनफिल्ट्रेट करोगे। घुसपैठ बोलते
हैं भाई। इनफिल्ट्रेट का मतलब एंटर करना।
दीवार कूदकर अंदर जाना। घुसपैठ बोलते हैं
जिसको जैसे चोरी करने वाले को इनफिल्ट्रेट
बोलते हैं। ठीक है? इनफिल्ट्रेट का समझ
में आ गया? इनफिल्ट्रेट का मतलब घुसपैठ
करना। ठीक है? आप दीवार कूदकर अंदर घुस
जाओगे। हमने यह सोचा भी नहीं था। अब
पेंटेस्टर का कहना क्या था? पेंटेस्टर का
कहने कहने का जो कंपनी थी जो कोल फायर थी
या जो टेस्टर था उनका कहने का वी वर आल्सो
मीन टू मेजर लो इनफोर्समेंट
रिस्पांस टाइम अलोंग वि द रिकॉर्ड्स
वनेबिलिटी उनका कहना यह था कि रिकॉर्ड्स
की वनेबिलिटी के साथ-साथ वो जो लॉ
इनफोर्समेंट है वहां की जो लॉ इन पुलिस है
उनका रिस्पांस टाइम भी देखना चाहते थे।
ठीक है? उसका रिस्पांस टाइम भी देखना
चाहते थे।
उन्होंने बोला कि जो कंपनी थी जो टेस्टिंग
करवा रही थी जो लोवा की जो एससीए थी स्टेट
कोर्ट एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर का जो अथॉरिटी
उन्होंने बोला कि नहीं हमें हमने सब
डिजिटल टेस्टिंग करवानी थी और हमने सोचा
भी नहीं था कि आप दीवार कूद के फिजिकली
बिल्डिंग के अंदर एंटर करने की कोशिश
करोगे। लेकिन वहीं पर जो टेस्टिंग कंपनी
थी उनके जो टेस्टर्स थे उन्होंने कहा कि
हमारा हम सिर्फ क्या कर हम रिकॉर्ड के
साथ-साथ हम क्या चेक करना चाहते हैं कि जो
लॉ इनफोर्समेंट है वहां की जो पुलिस वगैरह
का है उनका रिस्पांस टाइम भी हम देखना
चाहते थे कि ऐसा करने पर। ठीक है? बेसिकली
वी कैन से दैट देयर वाज़ ए क्लियर
मिसअंडरस्टैंडिंग बिटवीन बोथ साइड अबाउट द
ट्रू स्कोप ऑफ द इंगेजमेंट। दोनों के बीच
में मिस अंडरस्टैंडिंग थी। और उसका रिजल्ट
क्या हुआ? रिजल्ट यह हुआ जो पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर थे उनको कई घंटों तक जेल में रहना
पड़ा। कई घंटे उनको जेल में बिताने पड़े।
उसके बाद उन्हें अपनी जमानत करवानी पड़ी।
ठीक है? और प्रॉब्लम किसकी वजह से थी? जो
स्कोपिंग थी वो सही से नहीं हुई थी। बैड
स्कोपिंग की वजह से। बैड स्कोपिंग की वजह
से जो स्कोपिंग थी उसकी स्कोपिंग क्या थी?
पुअर थी। ठीक है? यहां सबक यह था कि अगर
स्कोपिंग सही से इंप्लीमेंट होती, उनके
बीच में अंडरस्टैंडिंग होती अच्छे से तो
उनको जेल में रात नहीं बितानी पड़ती या
कुछ घंटे उनको जेल में नहीं बिताने पड़ते।
उनके लिए उनको बेल नहीं करवानी पड़ती।
मतलब इतना बड़ा मैटर होता ही नहीं। बट हुआ
क्या कि एक मिसअंडरस्टैंडिंग हुई। दोनों
के बीच में अह और इस मिसअंडरस्टैंडिंग को
उन्होंने क्लियर नहीं किया। और जिसकी वजह
से बस आखिरकार जो रिजल्ट था रिजल्ट यह था
कि
उनको जमानत लेनी पड़ी लेकिन कुछ घंटे
दोनों पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स को जेल में
बिताने पड़े। अंडरस्टुड यह कहानी क्या थी?
केस स्टडी समझ में आई? केस स्टडी समझ में
आई?
यह चीज दोनों को समझ में आई?
ठीक है? यह चीज दोनों को क्लियर है कि दो
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स को जेल में जाना
पड़ा। बिकॉज़ उनके बीच में एक
मिसअंडरस्टैंडिंग थी। उनके बीच में
स्कोपिंग क्लियर नहीं था।
उनके बीच में स्कोपिंग क्लियर नहीं था।
ओके? तो अभी एज एन एथिकल हैकर। ठीक है? एज
एन एथिकल हैकर जो इतना बड़ा डिजास्टर हो
गया उससे हमें क्या सीखने को मिलता है?
उससे हमें सीखने को यह मिलता है कि अगर आप
कल को कोई फिजिकल पेन टेस्ट कर रहे हो।
अगर आप कल को कोई फिजिकल पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग कर रहे हो तो आपको क्या-क्या
प्रीकॉशंस लेने चाहिए? आपको क्या-क्या
सावधानी बरतनी चाहिए? नंबर एक सबसे पहला
फ्रीक्वेंट कम्युनिकेशन। फ्रीक्वेंट
कम्युनिकेशन। आपको हमेशा आप क्लाइंट के जो
पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट है उसके टच में रहना
है। हमेशा उसके टच में रहना है। अगर आपको
एक भी परसेंट डाउट आता है। जैसे कि इस
तरीके का डाउट अगर उन्होंने डाउट पूछा
होता कि सर क्या हम आपकी सिक्योरिटी
टेस्टिंग के लिए फिजिकल गेट को बाईपास कर
सकते हैं? दीवार कूदकर कूद सकते हैं या
फिजिकल गेट बाईपास कर सकते हैं। तो अगर इस
तरीके की चीजें आपके मन में आती हैं और
आपको श्योरिटी नहीं है तो आपको क्या करना
है? डायरेक्टली आपका जो पॉइंट ऑफ कांटेक्ट
है उससे कंफर्म करना है, क्लियर करना है,
पूछना है। बिना पूछे आपको क्या करना है?
डिसीजन नहीं लेना है। सबसे पहली चीज आपको
ध्यान रखनी है कि आपका जो पॉइंट ऑफ
कांटेक्ट है और आपके बीच में कम्युनिकेशन
बिल्कुल क्लियर होना चाहिए। आप कभी भी
सारी चीजें उसके साथ आप डिस्कस डिस्कस
करना आपको। दूसरी चीज क्या है आपकी?
व्हनेवर यू आर परफॉर्मिंग ऑन साइट फिजिकल
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग और सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
ऑलवेज कैरी ए नोटराइज्ड कॉपी ऑफ द फॉर्मल
ऑथराइजेशन लेटर वीडियो।
आप जब भी क्या कर रहे हो ऑन साइड ऑन साइड
फिजिकल पेन टेस्टिंग या सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
टेस्टिंग करने की कोशिश कर रहे हो तो आपको
हमेशा क्या करना है उनका जो फॉर्मल
ऑथराइजेशन लेटर की एक कॉपी हमेशा आपको
अपनी हर वक्त अपनी जेब में रखना है। ठीक
है? मतलब उनकी जो ऑथराइजेशन कॉपी है जो
उनका जो लेटर है या जो कॉन्ट्रैक्ट है
उसकी एक कॉपी हमेशा हर वक्त आपको अपनी जेब
में रखनी है। खासकर जब आप फिजिकल
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग या सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
परफॉर्म करने वाले हो इस टाइप की। क्यों?
ताकि कल को पुलिस आपको पकड़े तो आप उसको
दिखा सको। पुलिस को बता सको कि मेरे पास
ऑथराइजेशन है। अगर वह आपके पास नहीं होगी
आपको मंगाने पड़ेंगे। उस केस में भी आपको
क्या करना पड़ेगा? तब तक पुलिस स्टेशन में
वेट करना पड़ेगा। थर्ड चीज आपको ध्यान
रखनी है ईमेल ओवरवर्बल। ईमेल ओवरवर्बल
मतलब क्या करना है? फोन पर या बातोंब
बातों में
बोला गया कि हां आपने पूछा कि मैं ऐसा कर
सकता हूं। ठीक है? बातोंब बातों में और
उसने बोला कि हां हां आपको जो ठीक लगे वो
कर लो। तो इस चीज की कोई भी वैल्यू नहीं
है। जैसे मैंने आपको बताया जो वर्बल
कम्युनिकेशन है उसकी कोई वैल्यू नहीं
होती। हमेशा वैल्यू होती है डिजिटल
रिकॉर्ड्स की या फिजिकल रिकॉर्ड्स की। तो
उसके लिए आपको हमेशा क्या करना है? आपको
क्या करना है? अगर वर्बल आप कम्युनिकेशन
कर भी रहे हो तो उसके बाद उनको बोलो कि
मैं आपको इसके रिगार्डिंग एक मेल भेज रहा
हूं। प्लीज आप उसको कंफर्म करके उसका
रिप्लाई कीजिए। देन उसके बाद हम अपना काम
स्टार्ट करते हैं। इससे क्या होगा? आपके
पास एक डिजिटल रिकॉर्ड रहेगा क्योंकि जो
वर्बल कम्युनिकेशन होता है उसकी लीगल
प्रोटेक्शन बिल्कुल जीरो होती है। कोर्ट
में उसकी लीगल प्रोटेक्शन मानी नहीं जाती।
उसकी वैल्यू जीरो होती है। ठीक है? बातों
बातों में कही गई बात का कोई भी वैल्यू
नहीं है। कोई भी मोल नहीं है। इस तरह की
चीजों में। चौथी चीज क्या है? एक्सप्लसिट
डिनाइल्स। ठीक है? कॉन्ट्रैक्ट में
साफ-साफ लिखा होना चाहिए कि क्या-क्या
अलाउड है। ठीक है? क्या-क्या अलाउड है। और
इसके अलावा मैनेजमेंट को एक चीज ध्यान में
रखनी है। उनको एक्सप्लसिटली यह मेंशन करना
चाहिए क्या नहीं करना है। अलाउड के
साथ-साथ नॉट अलाउड भी क्या करना है? 100%
मेंशन करना है। जैसे कि फिजिकल एंट्री
स्ट्रिक्टली प्रोहबिटेड।
फिजिकल एंट्री स्ट्रिक्टली प्रोहबिटेड
जैसा कि हमने रियल वर्ल्ड एग्जांपल में
देखा। तो ये चार पांच चीजें चार चीजें
आपको ध्यान में रखनी है। जब भी आप क्या
करने वाले हो? इस तरीके की पेन टेस्टिंग
करने वाले हो। तो ये चार प्रिकॉशंस आप ले
लोगे। उससे क्या होगा? आप ऐसी सिचुएशन में
घेरने से बच जाओगे। अपना टाइम बचा लोगे
जिससे आपकी जो कररियर है, आपके जो
रेपुटेशंस है उस पे कोई दाग ना आए।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
अंडरस्टुड? समझ में आई ये बात?
यह बात आई समझ में?
अगर यह बात समझ में आ गई? अब आते हैं हम
हमारे ओडीए पर। ओडीए लूप के ऊपर। ठीक है?
ओडीए लूप। ओडीए मतलब ऑब्जर्व ओरिएंट,
डिसाइड एंड एक्ट। ओडीए लूप पर देखो ओडीए
लूप कोई आम साइबर सिक्योरिटी फ्रेमवर्क
नहीं है। ये सोशल इंजीनियरिंग और ओपन
सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस का सबसे पावरफुल इंजन
है। सबसे पावरफुल इंजन है। फॉर एग्जांपल,
मैं आपको बताता हूं। देखो आप लोगों ने
क्या किया होगा? हॉलीवुड मूवी देखी होगी।
डेफिनेटली सबने हॉलीवुड मूवी देखी होगी।
हॉलीवुड मूवी में क्या होता है कि एक हैकर
क्या करता है? कंप्यूटरर्स पर बैठता है। 2
मिनट में कुछ मैजिक कर मैजिक करके पूरे
सिस्टम का डाटा उड़ा देता है। ठीक है? एक
हैकर कंप्यूटर पर बैठता है। 2 मिनट में
कुछ मैजिक करता है। एंटर मारता है। पूरे
सिस्टम का डाटा क्या हो जाता है? बूम आउट
या डिस्ट्रॉय हो जाता है या वो पूरा डाटा
चुरा लेता है। लेकिन रियल लाइफ में ऐसा
कोई मैजिक नहीं होता। ठीक है? रियल लाइफ
में ऐसा कोई भी मैजिक नहीं होता। यह सिर्फ
हॉलीवुड मूवीज़ या फिल्मों में ही होता है।
लेकिन रियल लाइफ में ऐसा कोई मैजिक नहीं
होता। रियल वर्ल्ड पेन टेस्टिंग में क्या
होता है? रियल वर्ल्ड पेन टेस्टिंग में जब
आप कंप्यूटर के सामने इन रियल वर्ल्ड पेन
टेस्टिंग वेदर यू आर सिटी इन फ्रंट ऑफ़ अ
कंप्यूटर डूइंग होसेंट फॉर हावर्स और
ट्राइंग टू गेन फिजिकल एंट्री इंटू अ
टारगेट ऑफिस। योर माइंड इज रनिंग इन दिस
लूप एव्री सिंगल सेटिंग सेकंड। मतलब क्या
होता है? रियल वर्ल्ड पेन टेस्टिंग में जब
आप कंप्यूटर के सामने बैठकर घंटों तक ओपन
सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस करते हो या फिर आप
फिजिकली
जो टारगेट के ऑफिस में एंटर करने की कोशिश
करते हो तो हर वक्त आपका दिमाग हर एक
सेकंड में यह जो चारों लूप है ना इनको
घुमा रहा होता है। ऑब्जर्व, ओरिएंट,
डिसाइड और एक्ट। यह चारों लूप हमेशा क्या
करते रहते हैं?
आपके रोटेट करते रहते हैं। जब आप क्या
करते हो? रियल वर्ल्ड में पेन टेस्टिंग
करते हो। ओडीए लूप इज नॉट अबाउट स्पीड ऑफ
फिंगर्स। इट इज अबाउट स्पीड ऑफ थिंकिंग। द
फास्टर योर लूप द मोर कंट्रोल यू हैव ओवर
द इंगेजमेंट। जितना लूप यह फास्ट होगा,
उतना ज्यादा आपके अपनी इंगेजमेंट पे
कंट्रोल होगा। ठीक है? तो, अभी हम बात
करते हैं कि यह आया कहां से? यह जो लूप
है, यह आया कहां से? यह आया है एक
एयरफोर्स पायलट के माइंड सेट से। जो यह
लूप है, एक एयरफोर्स पायलट के माइंडसेट से
आया है। ठीक है? टू अंडरस्टुड अंडरस्टैंड
दिस लूप, वी नीड टू गो बैक ए लिटल इन
हिस्ट्री। इस लूप को समझने के लिए हमें
थोड़ा सा पीछे जाना पड़ेगा। एंड इट वाज
डिजाइन बाय कर्नल जॉन बोयट ए लेजिडरी
मिलिट्री स्ट्रेटजिस्ट ऑफ द यूनाइटेड
स्टेट एयरफोर्स फॉर फाइटर पायलट। ठीक है?
इसको यूनाइटेड स्टेट एयरफोर्स के एक
लेजेंड्री मिलिट्री जो स्ट्रेटजिस्ट होते
हैं जो स्ट्रेटजी बनाते हैं होते हैं उनके
एक कर्नल जॉन बोर्ड ने सॉरी फॉर प्रोनाउंस
कर्नल जॉन बोर्ड ने फाइटर पायलट के लिए
डिजाइन किया था ओडी लॉक को क्योंकि
क्योंकि व्हेन टू फाइटर जेट फेस ईच अदर इन
अ डॉग फाइट एट 15000 1500 किमी पर हावर दी
पायलट हु मेक द राइड डिसीजन फास्ट एंड
फास्ट विल सर्वाइव। मतलब
उनका मेन मोटो था यह लूप बनाने का कि
जब दो फाइटर जेट्स आमने-सामने 1500
कि.मी./ घंटे की स्पीड से डॉग फाइट करते
हैं तो पायलट दुश्मन से पहले जो सा पायलट
दुश्मन से पहले और सबसे पहले दुश्मन से
पहले और जल्दी डिसीजन लेगा वह जिंदा
बचेगा। मतलब इसका मेन मोटो क्या था? इस
लूप का इस लूप का मेन मोटो था कि
दो फाइटर पायलट्स जब वह डॉग फाइट कर रहे
हैं। डॉग फाइट करते वक्त डॉग फाइट होता है
आपस में लड़ाई करते हैं हवा में। उनकी
स्पीड बहुत ज्यादा होती है। 1500 या 2000
कि.मी. या 3000 कि.मी. प्रति घंटा। यह
स्पीड होती है। और जब इस स्पीड को फाइट
करते हैं तो जो पायलट अपने दुश्मन के बारे
में जितना जल्दी और जितना फास्ट सही
डिसीजन लेगा सिर्फ दोनों में से वही एक
जिंदा बचेगा। यह थ्योरी वहां से आई है इन
द साइबर वर्ल्ड। और साइबर वर्ल्ड में क्या
है? इसका क्या मतलब है? इट मींस स्टेइंग
टू स्टेप हेड्स ऑफ द टारगेट माइंड एंड
मूविंग बिफोर देयर डिफेंडर्स। अब क्या है
कि जो साइबर वर्ल्ड में इसका मतलब है
टारगेट के दिमाग से दो कदम आगे चलना और
उनके डिफेंडर से पहले मूव करना। हमें जब
तक आप अपने टारगेट से दो कदम आगे चलते
रहोगे और डिफेंडर से पहले मूव करते रहोगे
तो आपका जो अटैक है हमेशा सक्सेस रहेगा,
फास्ट रहेगा। ठीक है? यह है आपका ओडी लूप।
अंडरस्टुड समझ में आई यह बात
यह कहानी समझ में आई? हिस्ट्री इसकी ओडी
लूप की।
ओडी लूप कहानी समझ में आई।
ओके। सो अभी समझते हैं कि एक्चुअल में
देखो क्लाइंट साइड अटैक टेक्निक्स हमने
सीखी। ये थी। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक लाइफ
साइकिल हमने सीखी थी। और जो ओडीए लूप है
ये यहां पर सेट बैठता है। ठीक है? हमने
प्रीवियस क्लासेस में क्या सीखा? सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक लाइफ साइकिल के सात
फेजेस के बारे में सीखा। ये जो सेवन फेजेस
है सोशल इंजीनियर अटैक लाइसेंस इनके बारे
में हमने क्या किया है? प्रीवियस क्लासेस
में डिस्कस किया है। ठीक है? प्रीवियस
क्लासेस में डिस्कस किया है। हमने जिन
सेवन फेजेस के बारे में डिस्कस किया है
उसमें एक फेज है रिकॉन फेज। कौन सा फेज
है? एक ये आपका रिकॉन फेज ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस गैदरिंग फेज। ठीक है? ठीक है?
अब यह जो रिकॉन फेज है इस रिकॉन फेज और
इसके स्मूथ एग्जीक्यूशन के लिए इसके
एफिशिएंट एग्जीक्यूशन के लिए और इस फेज को
और भी ज्यादा एफिशिएंट एक्यूरेट बनाने के
लिए हम किसका यूज करते हैं? इस ओडीए लूप
का यूज़ करते हैं। इस ओडीए लूप का यूज़ करते
हैं। किसका यूज़ करते हैं? हम इस मॉडल का
यूज़ करते हैं। कौन सा? ओडीए लूप का यूज़
करते हैं। यह कहां पर फिट होता है आपका?
हमने मैंने आपको बताया था ना कि क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक टेक्निक्स में हमने एक्सपेंड
किया सोशल इंजीनियर अटैक लाइफ साइकिल।
सोशल इंजीनियर अटैक लाइफ साइकिल में जो
फेज टू है फज़ टू हमारा रिकॉन फेज है। ठीक
है? तो उसको एफिशिएंट बनाने के लिए हम एक
मॉडल का यूज़ करते हैं। उस मॉडल का नाम है
ओडीए मॉडल। उस मॉडल का नाम क्या है? ओडीए
मॉडल। कौन सा? ऑब्जर्व
ऑब्जर्व ओरिएंट डिसाइड और एक्ट। अब इसका
एक रूल है। इस रूल जो ये ओडीए लूप है इसका
एक रूल है। रूल क्या है? द फास्टर योर लूप
स्पिनस द इज़ियर यू बायपास द टारगेट
डिफेंस। मतलब जितनी तेजी से इस लूप को आप
घुमाओगे उस मतलब जितनी तेजी से इस लूप को
मतलब जितनी तेजी से तेजी से इस लूप को जो
घुमाएगा उसकी सक्सेस रेट उतनी ही ज्यादा
होगी। ठीक है? उसकी सक्सेस रेट उतनी ही
ज्यादा होगी।
मतलब सिंपल मतलब यह क्या है? जो जो भी
पेंटेस्टर्स है
वो जितनी तेज तेजी से इस लूप को क्या
करेगा? रोटेट करेगा
उतनी ही सक्सेस उसकी सक्सेस रेट क्या है?
वो ज्यादा होगी। और डिफरेंसेस को बाईपास
कर पाएगा। अंडरस्टुड?
अंडरस्टुड यह लूप कहां पर कहां से आया
आपका? इस पर हम इसके यहां पर इसको लूप को
क्या करने वाले हैं? पढ़ने वाले हैं इसके
लिए। इस लूप के बाद जो एक्ट के बाद क्या
होते हैं आपके? फिर ये सारे फज़ होते हैं।
डिज़ एंड अप्रूवल, इंप्लीमेंटेशन फज़,
डिटेक्शन फज़, मेज़रमेंट फज़ और रिपोर्टिंग
फज़। तो, एक-एक करके इन लूप के बारे में
समझते हैं। एक-एक करके जो ये लूप है, लूप
के जो भी फेसज़ हैं, इसके भी उनके बारे में
हम बात करते हैं। सबसे पहले हम ऑब्ज़र्व के
बारे में बात करेंगे। उसके बाद ओरिएंट के
बारे में। तीसरा हम डिसाइड के बारे में।
उसके बाद हम बात करेंगे एक्ट के बारे में।
तो सबसे पहले हम बात करते हैं ऑब्जर्व।
ऑब्जर्व मतलब कलेक्ट रो डाटा।
तो ऑब्जर्व का मतलब होता है देखना और डेटा
कलेक्ट करना। तो सबसे पहला स्टेप है रॉ
ऑब्जरवेशन।
यहां आप क्या करते हो? बिना किसी फ़िल्टर
के टारगेट के डाटा कलेक्ट करते हो। जो
आपका टारगेट है उसका डाटा कलेक्ट करते हो।
फॉर एग्जांपल आपने क्या किया कि आपने
टारगेट कंपनी के आईटी मैनेजर के जो Lindin
प्रोफाइल थी उसको ऑब्जर्व किया उसको देखा।
ठीक है? जब आपने
उसकी जो Lindin प्रोफाइल देखी उस पे एक
पोस्ट देखा ग्रेट डे एट दिस ऑफिस। उसने एक
पोस्ट देखा ग्रेट डे एट दिस ऑफिस। और आपने
क्या ऑब्ज़र्व किया? आपने देखा कि
बैकग्राउंड में एक वाइट बोर्ड है।
बैकग्राउंड में एक वाइट बोर्ड है उस इमेज
के। दूसरा आपने देखा टेबल के ऊपर एक क्या
रखा हुआ है? एक आई कार्ड रखा हुआ है। एक
आईडी कार्ड रखा हुआ है। अब वो किसका है?
चाहे इसका है या किसी और का भी है। लेकिन
टेबल के ऊपर एक आई कार्ड रखा हुआ है।
बैकग्राउंड में एक वाइट बोर्ड है जिसके
ऊपर कुछ टेक्निकल टर्म लिखी हुई हैं। और
जो आईडी बैज रखा हुआ है, उसका डिज़ाइन और
कलर विज़िबल है। ये चीज़ आपको समझ में आएगी।
तो, आप क्या करते हो? इस रो इमेज को क्या
करते हो? सेव करते हो फर्दर एनालिसिस के
लिए। इसको क्या करते हो? सेव करते हो
फर्दर एनालिसिस क्योंकि अभी आप ऑब्जर्व
फेस में हो। ऑब्जर्व फेस में आप क्या करते
हो? बिना किसी फिल्टर के पूरा-पूरा डाटा
कलेक्ट करते हो। नेक्स्ट आता है हमारा फिर
ओरिएंट फेस। ओरिएंट में क्या करते हो आप?
ओरिएंट में क्या करते हो आप? रुख तय करते
हो। मतलब आप उस रो डेटा को कॉन्टेक्स्ट
में कन्वर्ट करते हो। ठीक है? द ओरिएंट फज़
इज वेयर यू ट्रांसफॉर्म योर रो डेटा इंटू
मीनिंगफुल इंटेलिजेंस बाय अप्लाइंग योर
प्री एकिस्टिंग नॉलेज। ह्यूमन बायस एंड
एक्सपीरियंस
ओरिएंट का मतलब क्या हुआ? आप उस रो डाटा
को क्या करते हो? कॉन्टेक्स्ट देते हो। आप
अपनी जो नॉलेज है और जो आपकी जो कॉमन सेंस
है और जो आपका एक्सपीरियंस है तीनों चीज
का यूज़ करके आप क्या करते हो? उस डाटा को
एनालाइज करते हो। जो डाटा आपको क्या मिला
था? एक वाइट बोर्ड था। उसके बाद एक आईडी
कार्ड था। ये दो चीज़ आपने देखे थे। फॉर
एग्जांपल वाइट बोर्ड पे लिखा था माइग्रेशन
टू अजोर फेज टू
और आईडी कार्ड पे क्या है एक ब्लू स्ट्रिप
थी थोड़ा सा मतलब यह दिख रहा था यह आपका
आईडी कार्ड ठीक है आईडी कार्ड पे थोड़ा
ब्लू स्ट्रिप दिख रही थी हम इसमें ज्यादा
क्लेरिटी हम मान ले कि ब्लू स्ट्रिप दिख
रही थी कैसे फोटो लगी थी थोड़ा यहां पी
पीना टाइप का दिख रहा था लेकिन यह धुंधला
था टेक सॉल्यूशन या कंपनी का लोगो और वो
इस तरीके तो आपने क्या किया थोड़ा-थोड़ा
आईडिया लगा लिया अब ओरिएंटेशन में क्या
होगा कि दी वाइट बोर्ड शोज़ माइग्रेशन टू
अजर फज़ टू। दी कंपनी इज़ करेंटली वर्किंग
ऑन ए क्लाउड माइग्रेशन प्रोजेक्ट। मतलब
आपका दिमाग इसको प्रोसेस करेगा। प्रोसेस
करके उसको आईडिया मिला कि कंपनी क्या कर
रही है?
क्लाउड माइग्रेशन पे काम कर रही है। कंपनी
क्लाउड माइग्रेशन पे काम कर रही है। दूसरा
आपने क्या किया? आईडी कार्ड देखा। आईडी
कार्ड पे ब्लू स्ट्रिप थी। ब्लू स्ट्रिप
मतलब आपने सोचा कि एक स्टैंडर्ड
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर जो स्टैंडर्ड आईटी
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर है उसका यह बैज लग रहा है।
ठीक है? यह उसका एक बैज लग रहा है। और
दूसरा आपने क्या नोटिस किया? आप दूसरा
नोटिस किया कि अजोर माइग्रेशन चल रहा है
कंपनी में। इसका मतलब कंपनी में काफी हलचल
चल रही है। काफी अफरातफरी चल रही है और
काफी केस चल रहा है। काफी कस चल रहा है।
तो आपने क्या किया? आपने अपने
हाइपोथेसिस का यूज किया। आपने उसको
अपना-अपना अंदाजा लगाया कंफर्म करने के
लिए। और आपने क्या किया? उस कंपनी के बारे
में क्या किया? थोड़ा सा और गहरी जांच की।
थोड़ी गहरी इन्वेस्टिगेशन की। आपने सोडान
पे गए। सोडान पे आपने क्या किया कि चेक
किया कि क्या पहले
कोई अजोर बकेट अवेलेबल है? क्या एग्जिस्ट
करता है? है पब्लिकली एक्सप्लोज कोई अजोर
बकेट अवेलेबल है इस कंपनी के लिए आपने
सोडान पे गए शोडान टूल का यूज़ किया सोडान
पर आपने चेक किया क्या इस कंपनी के लिए
पहले कोई अजोर जो बकेट है पब्लिकली
एक्सपोज्ड है पहले से कोई अभी यह
माइग्रेशन चल रहा है लेकिन पहले से कोई
ऐसे कोई पब्लिकली एक्सपोज बकेट है अजोर की
दूसरा आपने क्या किया Twitter पे Twitter
पे आपने चेक किया कि क्या किसी कंपनी
कंपनी के एंप्लॉय ने aur माइग्रेंस जो
अजोर की जो माइग्रेशन है उससे रिलेटेड कोई
शिकायत की है? मतलब Twitter पे कोई शिकायत
की है क्या? कंपनी के किसी एंप्लई ने कि
कुछ प्रॉब्लम चल रही है या कुछ इशू आ रहे
हैं। कुछ
एरर्स आ रही हैं। ऐसी कुछ प्रॉब्लम्स फेस
कर रहे हो जो वो Twitter पर उन्होंने अपने
दुख को शेयर कर दिया हो या सोडान से आपको
पता लगा क्या पब्लिकली कोई एक्सपोज
बकेट अवेलेबल है क्लाउड के लिए अजोर की
पहले से कोई। यह चीजें आपने क्या किया?
अपना हाइपोथेसिस का यूज किया। अपने-अपने
अंदाजे को कंफर्म करने के लिए आपने जो
आपको अंदाजा था कि माइग्रेशन चल रहा है।
दूसरा ये चीज कंफर्म करने के लिए आपने
क्या किया? फदर थोड़ा सा इन्वेस्टिगेशन
किया। थर्ड स्टेप आता है आपका डिसाइड।
आपका डिसीजन मेकिंग। जब एक बार क्या कर
ले? आपके पास रो डाटा आ गया। आपने ऑब्जर्व
से आपने ऑब्जरवेशन से रो डाटा कलेक्ट
किया। उसके बाद आपका जो ओरिएंट था जो उस
वहां से आपको कॉन्टेक्स्ट आ जाता है। ठीक
है? उसके बाद आपको डिसीजन लेना होता है।
आपको फैसला लेना होता है। आपके रो डाटा और
आपके कांटेक्ट से आपको क्या लेना पड़ता
है? फैसला लेना पड़ता है। अब आपके पास दो
ऑप्शन है। पहला ऑप्शन है कि क्या मेरे पास
काफी डाटा है एक कस्टमाइज फेसिंग ईमेल
भेजने के लिए। एक फिशिंग ईमेल भेजने के
लिए जो मेरा डाटा है क्या वह सफिशिएंट है?
जैसे कि मैं क्या करूं? एक Microsoft ao
सपोर्ट इंजीनियर बनके ठीक है? एडमिन को
मेल भेज देता हूं कि आपकी जो क्लास
स्टोरेज है वह 100% फुल हो चुकी है। या
आपके पास दूसरा ऑप्शन क्या है? क्या या
डाटा कम है। अभी मेरे पास डाटा की कमी है
और मुझे फिजिकल एक्सेस ट्राई करना चाहिए
फेक आईडी कार्ड की हेल्प से। मतलब मेरे
पास डाटा इनसफिशिएंट है। दो ऑप्शन थे डाटा
सफिशिएंट है फिशिंग ईमेल करने के लिए।
करने के लिए। तो या दूसरा ऑप्शन क्या है?
दूसरा ऑप्शन था कि मेरे पास डाटा की कमी
है। मुझे फिजिकल एक्सेस चाहिए होगा। मुझे
उस उसकी एक फेक आईडी कार्ड बनानी पड़ेगी
उसके आईडी कार्ड की और मुझे फिजिकली एंटर
करना पड़ेगा। क्योंकि आईडी कार्ड का
पैटर्न्स वो सब मैंने क्या कर लिया?
आइडेंटिफाई कर लिया था। तो आपको क्या करना
है? डिसीजन में अगर आपको लगता है कि आपका
डाटा इनसफिशिएंट है। ठीक है? आपका डाटा
इनसफिशिएंट है तो आपको क्या है और आपको
क्या करना है फिजिकली इनफिल्ट्रेट करना
पड़ेगा मतलब फिजिकली इनफ्लेट मतलब कि
दीवार नहीं कूदना आपको फिजिकली फेक आईडी
से एंटर करना पड़ेगा या फिर आपको लगता है
कि क्रेडेंशियल चुराने के लिए फिशिंग सबसे
बेस्ट और स्टेथी ऑप्शंस है मतलब ऑप्शन ए
है कि आपको क्या करना है अभी उस मशीन के
क्रेडेंशियल चाहिए तो वह अह उसके लिए आपके
पास ऑप्शन इज़ द बेस्ट ऑप्शन ऑप्शन बी को
आप क्या कर रहे हो छोड़ रहे हो आपको ऑप्शन
ऑप्शन बी आपको नहीं चाहिए तो यहां पर आप
क्या करते हो डिसीजन लेते हो ऑप्शन ए या
ऑप्शन बी आप क्या करते हो डिसाइड में
डिसीजन लेते हो ऑप्शन ए या ऑप्शन बी अगर
आपको लगता है ऑप्शन बी है अगर आपको लगता
है आपके पास इंफॉर्मेशन कम है आप तो आप
बिना टाइम वेस्ट किए क्या करोगे
डायरेक्टली डिसाइड से क्या करोगे
डायरेक्टली अपने ऑब्जरवेशन फेज पे चले
जाओगे टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करोगे आपको लगा कि
ऑप्शन बी है। मेरे पास डाटा की कमी है कि
मेरे पास सफिशिएंट इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है। तो
मैं क्या करता हूं? वापस से हम स्टेप वन
पे चले जाएंगे। आपको बताना ये लूप है।
डिसाइड किया डाटा की कमी है। इंफॉर्मेशन
की कमी है। हम चले गए ऑब्जरवेशन स्टेज
में। फिर से हम डाटा कलेक्ट करेंगे। ठीक
है? फिर से हम डाटा कलेक्ट करेंगे।
नेक्स्ट आता है आपका एक्ट स्टेज। एक्ट में
क्या करते हैं? हम एक्शन लेते हैं। इट इज
अ टाइम टू टेक एक्शन। एग्जीक्यूट द डिसीजन
यू हैव मेड। फॉर एग्जांपल्स आपने क्या
किया? ऑप्शन ए डिसाइड किया। जब आपने ऑप्शन
ए डिसाइड किया फिर आपके जो बाकी के जो फेज
हैं जैसे मैंने आपको बताया था डिज़ एंड
अप्रूवल इंप्लीमेंटेशन यह सारे फज़ स्टार्ट
हो जाते हैं। क्योंकि आपने डिसाइड कर लिया
कि ओके ऑप्शन ए है। हम फेसिंग करेंगे।
उसके लिए आप क्या करोगे? उसके लिए आप क्या
करते हो? एक फेसिंग इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
डिप्लॉय करोगे। उनका उसके जैसा सेम डोमेन
क्या करो? सेटअप करोगे। उसके बाद फिशिंग
ईमेल सेंड करोगे। उसके बाद क्या करोगे आप?
वेट करोगे। उसके बाद आप क्या करोगे? वेट
करोगे। अभी एक चीज ध्यान रखना लूप बैकक
में क्या किया? आपने जैसे ही मेल भेजा तो
आपका काम खत्म नहीं हुआ। एज सून एज यू
एक्ट द टारगेट सिक्योरिटी सिस्टम एंड
एंप्लई विल रिएक्ट एंड देयर रिएक्शन
बिकम्स यह हुआ न्यू रो डाटा। जैसे आपने
क्या किया कि ईमेल भेजा तो आपका काम खत्म
नहीं हुआ। यहां से तो आपका काम शुरू हुआ
है। क्योंकि जैसे आप डाटा डाटा मेल भेजोगे
उसके जो सिक्योरिटी सिस्टम्स है या जो
एंप्लई है उसके ऊपर रिएक्ट करेंगे। अब
जैसे रिएक्ट करेंगे आपको क्या करना क्या
होगा? आपको नया डाटा मिलेगा। और जैसे अगर
आपको नया डाटा मिला तो आपको फिर से क्या
करना पड़ेगा? ऑब्जर्व ओरिएंट डिसाइड। फिर
से इस इस लूप को क्या करना पड़ेगा? आपको
चलाना पड़ेगा। अदरवाइज
अगर उन्होंने आपके फॉर एग्जांपल
सिक्योरिटी सिस्टम ने डिटेक्ट कर लिया या
फिर एंप्लई ने आपके हिसाब से काम नहीं
किया उसने क्या किया
उसने फिशिंग रिपोर्ट कर दिया इफ द टारगेट
रिपोर्ट द ईमेल ईमेल को रिपोर्ट किया तो
आप क्या करोगे यू ऑब्जर्व द न्यू डाटा फिर
आपका काम क्या है आप फिर से अपनी
ऑब्जरवेशन पे जाओगे नया डाटा फाइंड आउट
करोगे फिर वहां पर उसको क्या करोगे ओरिएंट
प्रिंट करोगे उस डाटा के हिसाब से
कॉन्टेक्स्ट बनाओगे फिर से आप डिसीजन लोगे
और फॉर एग्जांपल नेक्स्ट डिसीजन आपने क्या
लिया आपने अब की बार फिशिंग की बजाय आपने
बोला अब हम क्या करेंगे कॉल ओवर विशिंग
करेंगे कॉल ओवर विशिंग करेंगे अब की बार
हम क्या करेंगे कॉल करेंगे अब हम विशिंग
टेक्निक यूज़ करेंगे मतलब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
डिसीजन आपको क्विक लेना है अगर डाटा नया
आया तब भी आप उसको ऑब्जर्व करोगे उसके बाद
फिर उस पे डिसीजन लोगे कि इस डाटा का मुझे
क्या करना है फदर पोस्ट एक्सप्ल लोटेशन
करना है या इस डेट से मुझे क्या मिल रहा
है या फिर सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट आ गया
सिक्योरिटी वालों को पता चल गया तब भी
आपको अपनी टेिक्स बदलनी है फिर से नया
डाटा उठाना है आपको टेक्निक बदलनी है नए
डाटा पे आपको क्या करना है फिर से डिसाइड
करना है कि क्या करना है आपके पास जब
फेसिंग नहीं करनी अभी मुझे क्या करना है
स्पूफिंग करनी है या अभी मुझे क्या करना
है स्मिसिंग करनी है डमस्टर ड्राइविंग
करनी है ये करना है फटाफट आपने डिसीजन
लिया और एक्ट किया वहां पर भी इनसफिशिएंट
फिर से लूप गो बैक मतलब यह है
आप इसको क्या करते हो इस लूप को आप जब तक
चलाते हो जब तक आपका ऑब्जेक्टिव पूरा नहीं
हो जाता आपकी जो पूरी अटैक लाइफ साइकिल तब
काम करेगी जब ये मॉडल जब बीच में जो रिकॉन
के अंदर जो ये मॉडल है ये मैंने जैसे मैं
आपको बताया ना ये रहा यहां पर जो ये ओडीए
लूप है यहां पर जितना अच्छे से काम कर पा
करवा पाओगे इससे तब जाके आपकी जो बाकी की
जो स्टेजेस हैं परफॉर्म हो पाएंगी मतलब
आपके के सक्सेस रेट इस किस पिन पे है।
इसको कितना जल्दी आप कर पाते हो? इट ये जो
मॉडल है ओडीए लूप इसको कितना क्विकली आप
कर पाते हो? ये बाकी आपकी स्टेजेस को
डिसाइड करता है। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
मतलब यह लूप तब तक चलता है जब तक आपका
ऑब्जेक्टिव पूरा नहीं हो जाता। या फिर
आपका जो टाइम लिमिट खत्म नहीं हो जाती।
अंडरस्टुड?
समझ रहे हो सबको समझ में आया ओडी लूप क्या
होता है
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है
यहां तक सबको क्लियर है स्टूडेंट तो है ही
नहीं क्लियर किसको होगा चलिए फिर
जैसा कि मैंने आपको बताया दिस लूप्स कीप्स
रनिंग अंटिल योर ऑब्जेक्टिव इज अचीव्ड और
योर टाइम लिमिट एक्सपायर। यह लूप तब तक
चलता रहता है जब तक आपका ऑब्जेक्टिव
कंप्लीट नहीं हो जाता। आपका ऑब्जेक्टिव
अचीव नहीं हो जाता। या फिर आपकी जो टाइम
लिमिट है वो एक्सपायर नहीं हो जाती। अब
मैं एक और चीज बताता हूं। एक यहां पर लिखा
है ना प्रोटी फोर का क्लास। एक जो
प्रोफेशनल हैकर्स है वह हमेशा क्या करता
है? इस लूप के अंदर एंटर करने की कोशिश
करता है और लूप के अंदर जब एंटर करता है
तो वह क्या करता है कि इस लूप को इतना
फास्ट घुमाता है कि जब तक आपके जो ब्लू
ट्यूमर्स होते हैं वो डिफेंडर्स होते हैं
वो क्या करते हैं ऑब्जर्व और ओरिएंट का
डिसीजन लेते हैं जब तक वह ऑब्जर्व और
ओरिएंट स्टेज पर जाते हैं तब तक क्या कर
जाते हो आप एक्ट कर जाते हो तब तक आप एक्ट
करके आप काम खत्म करके निकल जाते हो ठीक
है तब तक आपका क्या है आप डिसीजन लेकर आप
एक्ट एक्ट कर चुके होते हो। आप एक एक्ट कर
चुके होते हो। तो यह जो स्पीड होती है,
इसको हम बोलते हैं ऑपरेशनल एडवांटेज।
मतलब आप आप भी ओडी लूप फॉलो कर रहे हो।
डिफेंडर भी ऑडियो लूप फॉलो कर रहा है। वो
भी ऑब्जर्व कर रहा है। ओरिएंट डिसाइड और
एक्ट कर रहा है। अभी ऑब्जर्व ओरिएंट
डिसाइड और एक्ट कर रहा है। लेकिन आपकी
स्पीड ज्यादा है और उनकी स्पीड कम है तो
ऑब्वियसली आप क्या होगा? जब तक वह ऑब्जर्व
और ओरिएंट करेंगे ओरिएंट स्टेट पे होंगे
तब तक क्या करोगे? आप एक्ट कर जाओगे। तब
तक तो आप क्या कर जाओगे? एक्ट कर जाओगे।
टाइम लिमिट आपकी पेन टेस्टिंग की जो
ड्यूरेशन उस पर डिपेंड करता है कि आपको
टेस्टिंग कितने दिन में कितने घंटों में
खत्म करनी है। उसके ऊपर डिपेंड करता है कि
यह तो हमेशा चलेगा। देखो आप फॉर एग्जांपल
आपको इनिशियल एक्सेस मिला। इनिशियल एक्सेस
करने के बाद एक नॉर्मल सिनेरियो तो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग है। आप नॉर्मल पेन टेस्टिंग
पे आ जाओ। इंटरनल पेन टेस्टिंग स्टार्ट
होगी। फिर ऑब्वियसली क्योंकि इंटरनल
एक्सेस मिल चुका है। उसके बाद आप एनम मैप
रन कर रहे हो। बाकी कमांड्स रन कर रहे हो।
वहां पे और कोई डाटा मिला है। कोई
वलनेबिलिटी मिल गई तब भी क्या करते हो आप?
सोचते हो ना डाटा मिलने के बाद फिर उसके
लिए क्या करते हो तो कोई पेलोड ढूंढते हो
कोई कमांड ढूंढते हो उस पे फदर क्या
रिकॉर्न करते हो या उसको एक्सप्लइट करते
हो या उसके लिए कोई आपके पास पहले से कोई
पेलोड पड़ा है कोई टूल उस पे रन करते हो
कोई फाइल आपने क्या किया उसकी परमिशन गलत
थी उस फाइल को रीड कर लिया फाइल ने डेटा
मिल गया सारी चीजें क्या है वही तो कर रहे
हैं हम देखो मैंने आपको टॉपिक बता दिया
आपको आज ध्यान आ रहा है कि ओके ये टैक्टिक
होती है लेकिन हम वही तो कर रहे हैं आप
अगर आपने डे वन से क्लासेस देखी होंगी।
हमने जब इंटरनल पेन टेस्टिंग सीखी थी
उसमें क्या किया था? रिकॉन करते थे,
स्कैनिंग करते थे, एनुमिशन करते थे,
एक्सप्लइटेशन, पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन यही तो
करते थे। आखिरकार हम फ्लैग ढूंढते थे, रूट
फ्लैग ढूंढते थे। उसमें कर क्या रहे थे?
हर बार इंफॉर्मेशनेशन पे हम रिएक्ट कर रहे
थे। हर बार इंफॉर्मेशनेशन पे हम पहले उस
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन को ऑब्जर्व कर रहे थे। उसके
लिए एक कॉन्टेक्स्ट ढूंढ रहे थे। फिर हमने
डिसाइड किया कि हमें क्या करना है। इस
पोर्ट पे जाना है। उस पोर्ट पे जाना। जैसे
पोर्ट 80 है। पोर्ट 80 को हमने सर्च किया।
वहां पर लॉग इन पेज मिला। उस पे ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स अटैक किया। ब्रस को अटैक करके
एक्सेस गेन कर लिया। मतलब सब कुछ वही तो
कर रहे थे। बट आज मैंने आपको यह एहसास
दिला दिया कि यह टैक्टिक होती है। ये
टैक्टिक भी यूज़ होती है। तो आज आप सोच रहे
हो कि कितना टाइम क्योंकि हम कर रहे हैं
बट हमें चीजें नहीं पता। और मैंने वो
चीजें बता दी तो आज आपको याद आ रहा है कि
ओ ये ऐसा अंडरस्टुड?
चलो लास्ट एंड आखरी स्लाइड।
जो आपके मन में चल रही होगी जो आप सोच
रहेगे। अब बहुत सारे लोग सोचते भी हैं,
बहुत से लोग बोलते हैं सर हमारा काम तो
कंपनी में कोस मचाना है। कस कस मचाना है
मतलब उथल-पुथल मचाना है। मतलब सम सोशल
इंजीनियर्स से आवर जॉब इज टू क्रिएट कस इन
द ऑर्गेनाइजेशन। हमारा काम है उथल-पुथल
मचाना ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर। एंड दिस इज
ट्रू। रियल अटैकर्स आर एक्साइटिंग। रियल
अटैक्स आर एक्साइटिंग ओनली व्हेन द सिस्टम
इज शेकन। और यह बात सही है। रियल अटैक का
मजा तभी है जब आप सिस्टम में क्या करते
हो? उथल-पछ उथल और पुथल मचाते हो। बट
लेकिन
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] लेकिन लेकिन
यहां पर क्या है कि क्य मचाने में भी एक
मजा है। लेकिन तब अगर उसको हम एक मेथड के
साथ मचाए। ठीक है? एक प्रॉपर मेथड यूज़
होना चाहिए क्योंकि वी आर एथिकल हैकर एज
एथिकल हैकर हम प्रॉपर मेथड्स मेथड कौन सा
है मेथड टू मैडनेस प्रॉपर मेथड्स का यूज
करके परमिशन के साथ जब हम केस मचाते हैं
तो एंड में क्या होता है सबका भला होता है
अगर आप ब्लैक हेट हैकर की तरह केस मचाओगे
आप उसमें उथल-पुथल करोगे तो उसमें ना तो
आपका भला है ना ऑर्गेनाइजेशन का भला है।
किसी का भी भला नहीं है। सबका बुरा है।
लेकिन जब एक प्रॉपर मेथड के साथ आप क्या
करते हो? केस करते हो। आप
सब कुछ करते हो जो एक ब्लैक हैकर हैकर
करता है। तब जब उस पे टेस्टिंग का उस
टेस्टिंग का एंड होता है। एंड में उसमें
सभी का भला होता है। कैसे आपका क्या भला
होता है? आपको पैसे मिलते हैं। आपकी
रेपुटेशन बनती है और जो कंपनी है उनको
उनकी असली वैल्यू मिलती है। उनको पता चलता
है कि क्या-क्या कमियां है। उनको
कहां-कहां इंप्रूवमेंट करना चाहिए,
क्या-क्या करना चाहिए, क्या-क्या
सिक्योरिटी प्रैक्टिससेस फॉलो करनी चाहिए,
पॉलिसी अपडेट करनी चाहिए, प्रोसीजर
अपग्रेड करने चाहिए या हमें सिस्टम
अपग्रेड करने चाहिए। और इससे एक और चीज
है। अगली बार से कंपनी आप ही को
कॉन्ट्रैक्ट देगी क्योंकि
आपकी जो इमेज है ना वह पॉजिटिव इमेज है।
आपने वह किया जिसमें दोनों का भला था।
मतलब उनका तो भला किया गया कि खुद का भी
होगा और नेक्स्ट टाइम के लिए भी प्रोजेक्ट
आपके पास ही आएगा। तो कस मचाना है तो मचाओ
लेकिन प्रॉपर मेथड्स के साथ प्रॉपर एथिकल
हैकिंग वे में ब्लैकहेट वे में सिर्फ एक
ही एक ही चीज है जो हम एक केस स्टडी पढ़
चुके हैं वो तो ऑथराइज था तब भी उनको यह
झेलना पड़ गया और अगर अन ऑथराइज तरीके से
हम करेंगे तो आपकी जिंदगी में केस मच
जाएगा और जिंदगी का केस किसी के पास सशन
नहीं होता अगर आपके पास अगर एक बार जिंदगी
में केस लग गया एक बार केस मच गया। एक बार
प्रॉब्लम आनी स्टार्ट हो गई तो तो भैया
बात ऐसी है। जॉब तो छोड़ो ही छोड़ो। कोई
आपको
आपका जो रिज्यूुमे है ना उसको भी वो
एक्सेप्ट नहीं करेगा क्योंकि
आपका पूरा पूरा करियर जो आपके जो फ्यूचर
है पूरा बर्बाद हो जाता है। तो इसलिए मैं
आपको आपको मैं इसीलिए सिखा रहा हूं कि
भैया जो कुछ करो ना प्रॉपर ऑथराइजेशन करो।
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। आपके पास अथॉरिटी
होने चाहिए मुंह पे मारो कि हां मेरे पास
अथॉरिटी थी। क्योंकि जब आप बग बाउंट करते
हो बग बाउंट में जो आप स्कोप लिखा स्कोप
के बेसिस पर टेस्टिंग करते हो ना बग बाउंट
करते हो तो वहां पर आपको कोई पकड़ता नहीं
क्योंकि कंपनी ने वहां पर करने के लिए
बोला है लेकिन किसी दिन अगर वहां पर आउट
ऑस्कोप वाली आप टेस्टिंग करना उसको
रिपोर्ट करके देखना पहले तो एक्सेप्ट करते
नहीं ओके और हो सकता है उसके इल
इललीगल सरकमस्ट्ससेस भी फेस करने पड़ सकते
हैं तो ऐसा मत कीजिएगा अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन
तो यह था आज का सेशन और
यहां तक आई होप उम्मीद करता हूं कि सबको
समझ में आ गया होगा। मैं आपको जो समझाने
की कोशिश कर रहा था तो प्लीज बता दीजिए।
सबको समझ में आई चीजें?
क्लास अच्छी लगी आज की या नहीं लगी? बताओ।
क्लास अच्छी लगी या नहीं लगी? यह भी बताओ।
अच्छी थी क्लास।
सबको
सारी चीजें समझ में आ गई?
देखो आप इसको इंफॉर्मेशन समझ सकते हो।
इसको आप टैक्टिक समझ सकते हो क्योंकि यह
वह चीज है जो आप एक्चुअल में प्रैक्टिकली
फॉलो करते हो बट आपको बस वो पता नहीं होती
कि मैं जो चीजें कर रहा हूं प्रैक्टिकली
अगर उनको मुझे किसी को टेक्निकली बोलना
पड़े बताना पड़े तो हम कैसे बताएंगे तो इस
तरीके से है कि आपने
ये ये स्टेप फॉलो किए इस स्टेप में ये था
इसमें आप इतने डीप में ये किए आपने लिंक
करते कोरिलेट करते जाओगे जैसे कि मैंने
आपका आपका जो डायग्राम से मैंने जैसे उसको
कोरिलेट किया है तो मे बी दिस इज़ द बेस्ट
वे टू रिप्रेजेंट किसी भी अथॉरिटी को कि
आप रिपोर्ट लिखोगे ओके वो समझेंगे कि आप
स्टेप बाय स्टेप सारे काम कर रहे थे यू आर
अ वेरी वेरी प्रोफेशनल आप अनप्रोफेशनल हो
ही नहीं सकते
ओके अच्छी बात है
थैंक यू अगर आप लोगों को
अच्छा लगा हो और नेक्स्ट क्लास के बारे
में बताता हूं। कल मे बी आई विल ट्राई कि
कल क्लास मैं ले पाऊं। अगर कल के क्लास
मैं नहीं ले पाया तो मंडे को क्लास आपकी
पक्का लूंगा क्योंकि कल मुझे कम चांसेस लग
रहे हैं कल की क्लासेस के। अगर सोच लेना
2:00 बजे तक अनाउंसमेंट नहीं आई क्लास के
लिए तो कल क्लास नहीं होगी। ओके? अदरवाइज
क्या है कि आपकी मंडे को क्लास होगी और
मंडे से जो क्लास स्टार्ट होने जा रही है
वह क्लास स्टार्ट हो रही है आपकी कौन सी
आपकी क्लास स्टार्ट हो रही है
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट एंड वेपनाइजेशन की।
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट एंड वेपनाइजेशन के ऊपर
आपकी क्लास स्टार्ट होगी। नेक्स्ट
अभी हम धीरे-धीरे आगे बढ़ रहे हैं।
हां बिल्कुल हम ऑडियो लूप डेली फॉलो करते
हैं ड्यूरिंग पे टेस्टिंग बट नोबडी नोज़ कि
हम
टेक्निकली बात करें तो क्या चीजें कर रहे
हैं
यार पीपीटीज का मैं कुछ सशन निकाल रहा हूं
आप लोगों के लिए क्या करना है क्या करना
है मुझे भी समझ में नहीं आ पा रहा है कि
कैसे शेयर करूं मैं आप लोगों के लिए
पीपीटी तो मैं देना चाहता हूं आप लोगों को
जल्दी इसका सोलशन निकाल लूंगा मैं वैसे
तो नेक्स्ट क्लास का आपको पता चल गया
पता चल गया।
चलिए तो अच्छी बात है। नेक्स्ट क्लास आपकी
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट एंड वेपनाइजेशन से
स्टार्ट होगी। उसके बारे में डिस्कस
करेंगे। चीजें क्या होती है? उसके बाद हम
क्या करेंगे? हम
अपनी
कंटिन्यू करेंगे। फिर हम मै डेवलपमेंट पे
बात करेंगे। उसके बाद धीरे-धीरे हम सारी
चीजें सीखेंगे। और फॉर योर काइंड इनेशन
मैं आप लोगों के लिए दो चीजें रेडी करने
की कोशिश कर रहा हूं। पहली चीज यह है कि
जो आपका फेसिंग सिमुलेशन है, प्रैक्टिकल
सिमुलेशंस है, उसकी तैयारी कर रहा हूं।
जिस दिन आई एम कॉन्फिडेंट कि मैं आपको वो
करवा पाऊंगा प्रैक्टिकली उसी दिन से हम
आपका रजिस्ट्रेशन लेना स्टार्ट करेंगे और
उसका हम प्रैक्टिकल सिमुलेशन दिखा देंगे।
दूसरी चीज यह है कि मैं आप लोगों के लिए
एक फ्री ओनली जो सोशल इंजीनियरिंग की जो
क्लास खत्म हो जाएगी उस दिन के बाद मैं
आपको थोड़ा टाइम दूंगा और उसका एक हम
इंजेक्ट एग्जाम कंडक्ट करेंगे थ्री टू फोर
आवर्स का जो आप फ्री में दे पाओगे। आपके
लिए कोई भी पैसा नहीं लिया जाएगा। आई एम
प्लानिंग बस उसकी मैं श्योरिटी नहीं कह
सकता ताकि आप लोगों को मजा आए उस चीज में।
ओके राधे मैं करवाता हूं। उसमें भी करवाता
हूं। करवाता हूं करवाता हूं। आप लोगों की
कंप्लेन है मुझे पता है
वहां पर करवाता हूं मैं करवाता हूं मैं
अपडेट करवाता हूं क्योंकि क्या हुआ बीच
में कुछ पीपीटीज मेरी वो हो रखी हैं और
उसका जो इमेज वो डिलीट हो रखी हैं
पर इनकी मैं जल्द से जल्द करवा दूंगा
बाकी किसी को कोई डाउट है क्लास से
रिलेटेड तो बताइए
अब जो चीजें समझा रहा हूं समझ लो क्योंकि
इसी टाइप के लॉजिकल क्वेश्चंस में रख
लूंगा फिर अगर मैं आपको एग्जाम लिया तो
ओके
तो किसी को कोई डाउट नहीं है सेशन को एंड
करें फिर
सेशन को एंड करें फिर अगर किसी को कोई
डाउट नहीं है
कोई डाउट नहीं
जल्दी बताओ यस या नो
बता दिया जाएगा अभी मैं
देखो सारी चीजें अंडर प्रोसेस है मेरे
माइंड में है आप लोगों के लिए चीजें
क्योंकि अभी खत्म नहीं हुआ सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग वाला यह चीज है। अभी कभी कभी
कभी कभी कभी कभी कभी कभी कभी कई क्लासेस
आएंगी तब तक तो मैं सोच लूंगा।
चलिए फिर एंड बाय-ब एवरीवन एंड सेशन को आज
एंड करते हैं। कल के सेशन चांस कम है होने
के बट कल के बाद नेक्स्ट डे हो सकता है।
क्योंकि दो सेशन के मैं प्रॉमिस कर रखा है
सैटरडे संडे। किसी कारण से एक दिन मैं
सेशन नहीं ले पाता। तो नेक्स्ट डे मंडे या
ट्यूसडे को जैसे अवेलेबल होता है अह
टाइमलाइन मेरे लिए मैं आपका सेशन ले लेता।
जैसे लास्ट टाइम हमने ट्यूसडे को लिया था।
ओके तो चलिए फिर बाय-ब गुड नाइट एवरीवन
एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन।